the reddit discussion forum continues to
grow david pakman.com slash reddit we
now are up to at latest check over 2100
viewers and listeners that are regularly
engaging in discussion with me Pat is on
the david packard show reddit discussion
forum i wanted to go through just a few
of the interesting conversations and
posts over the last few days at david
pakman.com slash reddit that i hope you
will jump in on number one uh a user
named plea 2k16 asked why are so many
all writers afraid to express their
views i don't agree that they are i
believe that alt writers are uh
incredibly comfortable expressing their
views as we've seen in so many different
venues and across multiple platforms
during the 2016 campaign and if anything
they've been emboldened by the election
of President Donald Trump I disagree
with the premise another discussion from
our reddit discussion forum is Hillary
Clinton going to do some confessions
this user says it seems to be so that
Hillary Clinton has lost most reasons to
be extra careful in statements and
interviews she can speak more freely at
least when the topic does not involve
classified top secret information maybe
she has some explosive confessions and
revelations to give something with
magnitude similar to revealing that she
is an atheist or that she used to smoke
pot or that she wants snorted cocaine
yeah I don't know that I see that
happening I I big it's it's an
interesting idea that now that by all
indications Hillary Clinton's political
career is starting to wrap up beyond I
don't know maybe involvement in a
potential Chelsea Clinton run for for
the house which we've heard some
rumblings of I'm not expecting any
bombshell confessions from Hillary
Clinton and whether it's because she's
not going to confess her because she has
nothing to confess I know that different
people our audience have different views
about that but I would not hold my
breath waiting for major Hillary
confessions another allegation from the
David
Ackman reddit discussion forum is that I
need to stop siding with the corrupt DNC
one user on our reddit discussion forum
said David have you had a chance
recently to look at your like to dislike
ratio on your YouTube videos or the
comments particularly on your siding
with the CIA on the Russian hacking yes
there are some trolls but there are many
fans like myself who just plainly don't
understand your point of view as of late
I want to say I love your show have been
a fan for a while but I'm noticing that
no matter the argument if it's against
the democratic party you write it off as
not true or fake news uh I disagree with
the premise here I I don't know how
anyone could see any of the of the
critiques and criticisms that I did of
what happened in Trump versus Clinton in
2016 I've been incredibly critical of
the DNC I've been criticizing the DNC
all along for having their hands on the
scale in a way that was both
anti-democratic and pragmatically
unsound in terms of supporting Hillary
Clinton over Bernie Sanders in the
Democratic primary uh did I I again
disagree with the premise I think you
can only come away with this point of
view as i said in the comments of
because i participate in these
discussions on reddit you could only
really come away with this point of view
if you've not been paying attention to
the show or or have been only
cherry-picking what you pay attention to
jumping Jim farmer on our reddit
discussion forum asked about a student
membership price wondering if there was
a code for student membership yet there
is indeed I mean it's not specifically a
student membership price but we have a
coupon code I voted 17 it's all one word
and all lower case and we want
membership support membership support is
the number one funding source for the
show but I'm not looking to break the
bank for people who can't afford the
normal prices so the coupon code I voted
17 which will work for any of the
membership levels at david pakman.com
slash membership that will give you a
major discount and consider it a student
discount price it's really just a
discount price uh for whoever needs it
or wants it and then lastly uh a viewer
starting a discussion
on reddit saying so I finally got around
to listening to the Pakman drunken
peasants appearance I think David did a
pretty good job representing a normal
non strawman progressive he should
definitely appear on more centrist
right-leaning podcast because he made
very compelling reasons to vote and
defended his viewpoints very well in the
individual is also linking to my
appearance on the drunken peasants yeah
interestingly enough david pakman show
producer pat forde actually was the
catalyst for getting me on drunken
peasants suggesting it and then actually
making the uh making the booking happen
and a lot of people responding
positively to it although i'm not sure
that i would call the drunken peasants
center right i think that they are sort
of generally left uh sort of libertarian
oriented that's the impression I got
from from talking to them so in any case
join the conversation david pakman.com
slash reddit subscribe free there
suggest topics for the show whatever
whatever makes sense to you read it is
sort of a pretty good place for any of
it